Do bras really cause breast cancer, or is
that just a myth perpetuated by hippies and
perverts?
Hey guys, Tara here for Dnews - and it seems
like cancer is one of those weird areas of
medicine that people love to develop theories
about.
“Don’t eat that food - it contains cancer
chemicals” “Don’t use products that
contain parabens, they’ll give you cancer!”
But what about bras?
I mean aside from sucking, can they really
cause cancer?
Not a lot of people gave much thought to that
question, until 2005 - when a book was published
by authors who claimed to have evidence of
a link between bras and breast cancer.
The idea was that bras impede on the circulation
and drainage of your lymphatic system, which
interferes with your body’s waste removal
process, and boosts your risk for breast cancer.
A lot of media outlets immediately grabbed
onto that story, and ran with it - supporting
it with the fact that breast cancer is more
common in developed countries - which they
claim, could’ve been related to the fact
that women in those areas are more likely
to wear bras.
It makes sense to a point, but according to
a new study - it’s also blatantly false.
For their study, researchers evaluated over
1,000 women who had been diagnosed with breast
cancer between 2000 and 2004, comparing them
to 469 women who didn’t have breast cancer.
They also gathered a bunch of data on the
types of bras those women wore - including
cup size and the presence of an underwire
- as well as when they began wearing them,
and how many hours a day they wore them.
Any confounding factors, like family history
of breast cancer, height, weight, race, income,
etc - were all accounted for.
According to researchers, their results definitively
found no evidence that wearing a bra increases
a woman’s risk for breast cancer.
It seems no matter how often you wear a bra,
or what kind of bra you wear - the risk is
the same either way.
So burn your bra, don’t burn your bra - whatever
you choose!
Because either way, it does not matter.
And hey - if you’re itching to learn more
about the wonderful world of bras, let me
point you to another show I host called Anyhoo,
where we recently did an episode with 8 busty
facts about bras.
For instance - did you know that the largest
bra size ever recorded was a 102 ZZZZ?
I’ll bet you didn’t - and it’s that
kind of hard-hitting investigative reporting
that we love here at Discovery.
If you wanna check out more of Anyhoo, just
head over to youtube.com/revision3 - and in
the meantime, if you guys have any questions,
comments, rants about bras maybe - just leave
em in the comments below.
Otherwise, thanks for watching!